good morning everyone
we'll call this meeting of the house
judiciary committee to order
and as usual we will begin today by
pledging allegiance and representative
simpson would you like to lead us in the
against
the united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands
one nation under god
mr clerk would you mind calling the role
today
uh thank you mr chairman uh
representative gordon here
representative mccoy here
representative sylvia here
representative welper is here
representative alexander here
representative lasalles
here
representative notter
representative merner here
representative kelly
representative trottier representative
andrus
representative smith
representative woods
representative oregon
here
representative
diorenzo
representative chase here representative
muse
here
representative macbeth here
representative page
representative simpson here
we have 20 mr chairman
thank you mr clerk
and and note that we do have some
substitutes here today
representative lasalles is here today
and we have representative muse
and representative woods here today
we'll plan to go through the our
business uh and my plan today
maybe because that's the way i'm
organized but uh in terms of the bills
from the lowest numbered bill to the
i we do have one person who's absent
right now and i'll
defer to the
ranking member in the other party and
indicate that if at some point in time
you feel it would be appropriate to take
up a particular bill
representative smith would you let me
know and we'll pass over that until
first bill that we'll address today is
senate bill 216 an act establishing a
commission to study the landlord and
tenant mediation program in circuit
courts
turn on your microphone
mr chairman i'm moving expedient to
legislator on senate bill 216.
okay it's moved by
representative walper in expedient the
legislature is there a second to that
i'll second it
seconded by representative mclean would
you like to address your motion
uh yeah mr chairman
the court is doing is doing this pilot
program for landlord tenant mediation
they reported it's working very very
successfully
and so
we didn't see any reason why they needed
a commission to find out how they're
doing
thank you is there other discussion with
regard to
um
representative d lorenzo
thank you mr human and just to um
address the concerns that
my friend from stratford has um
the
the program is a pilot program
um
initially and
we're looking at establishing a
committee to study the mediation program
in order to make it perhaps permanent if
the commission so wishes
now the bill would create a commission
to study the landlord tenant mediation
pilot program that has been going on in
the circuit courts the program was
developed by the circuit courts to help
landlords and tenants work through
issues to avoid an eviction mediation is
not mandatory and both the landlord and
tenant must agree on mediation
the pilot group program has been a great
success and has kept 80 percent of
tenants facing eviction in their homes
the study commission would provide the
general court with all relevant
stakeholders with an appropriate venue
to analyze the program
assess what is what has and has not
worked and recommend changes going
forward
the mediation approach is conciliatory
rather than punitive and could lead to
preservation of tenancy and prevent
homelessness
now a lot of um
jurisdictions
throughout the country have what's
called a housing court
so this would be kind of a mini housing
court without the framework of a housing
court per se
um
and it looks to resolve disputes and
namical full spec fashion and it's been
pretty successful throughout the country
thank you
thank you representative other other
comments
i just want to also underline did
anybody who sat through landlord-tenant
bill hearings know the
relationship between the
landlord landlord community
property owner community and the tenant
community is sometimes troubled and
even though i think both sides are
acting good face i think
the mediation program would be uh useful
especially right now when there's
um
the prices are
prices are unaffordable for working
people and there's less than a one
percent vacancy rate so the um
this evens the balance a little bit
where
even though they don't seem pleased with
this current state of affairs the
landlords do have like a very uh you
know it is a seller's market for them
and they have a very favorable position
so
um
so it's uh that's why i think this uh
this i think this commission is useful
even though it's only going to meet a
seeing none okay so we're ready to vote
on the motion the motion that's pending
is a motion of inexpedient to legislate
representative wilper our clerk would
you mind taking the role on that motion
on the motion of
on the motion of inexperience and
legislate senate bill 216
representative mclean
yes
representative sylvia yes representative
walpole ts representative alexander yes
representative wassel yes representative
naughter yes
representative mirner yes representative
kelly yes representative charlier yes
representative andrus yes representative
smith
no
representative oregon no
representative delorenzo
representative chase no representative
muse
no
representative langley's not here
representative macbeth no
representative page no
representative simpson no mr chairman
in the affirmative
affirmative nine negative
adopted the recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate will there be a
yes
and representative dilorenzo will be
representative lorenzo would that be
ought to pass
our next item in business is senate bill
217 an act relative to eviction notices
mr chairman i
move inexpedient to legislate on
sb
217.
and is there a second to the motion
seconded by representative alexander
moved by
representative sylvia and seconded by
representative
alexander to make senate bill 217
in expedient to legislate and would you
like to address your motion
yes indeed uh thank you i
it everybody knows that we have a
tremendous problem with the housing and
rental units in the state
there's no doubt about that
and everything that
imposes more restrictions on properties
reduces
the number of apartments that are going
to be available
this bill would
discourage landlords from buying
apartments
and in fact would encourage landlords to
sell their properties and perhaps turn
them into just single-family homes if
they are single families so
this really takes
uh
the wrong approach
it's well intended to no doubt but
the actual effect
economics is
undeniable it will cause
higher rents and less available
apartments so
while it's uh it may seem like it it
does good for uh folks that are renting
it it actually will have the reverse
effect
representative smith
thank you mr chairman and with
my
usual heartfelt respect to my colleague
on this
we differ
um
let's let's move out of manchester
nashua southern
new hampshire and go up to the lakes
region just for example i'll pick the
lakes region
in the lakes region there is a landlord
with
370 apartments
i don't know about you but 370
apartments is really to me very big for
new hampshire
um
and uh
the executive director of this program
wrote to us to express support
for sb217t
for the same reasons that were mentioned
but different conclusions
um
as you all know in in her letter to her
she said the rental market's extremely
tight it can take a household several
months to find a new apartment giving
people who face eviction through no
fault of their own
more time to relocate is the right thing
to do
we know that there's a good chance the
tenants in this situation can end up
homeless
simply due to the lack of available
rental apartments and when they're
homeless
they begin to fall through the rabbit
hole and have significantly more
problems that come back
to haunt
those of us who are more fortunate and
those of us by the way who pay taxes in
our cities and towns
so i would
respectfully disagree
with the mover of the motion and
and ask that the
committee
vote down the itl motion so that
we could um
move to otp
other questions or comments
representative lorenzo thank you mr
chairman
well
you know the the prime driver of this
bill
um 217 to relative to eviction notices
was
was um
drawn
to address
housing changes like
condominium conversion
um
or real rehabilitation of
which
the tenants have to move out of the
building so that it can be rehabilitated
so what's happened often is that once
tenants move out um
the
building is rehabbed and then
if it had if it had like a lot of um
low-income tenants those low-income
tenants would not be able to move back
into the property virtually making them
um potentially homeless
so the reason for this bill is to give
the tenants more time
to make other housing arrangements
and that's all it is
so it comes up when um
a tenant design a landlord decides to
sell a property and the tenant has to
move also when the landlord needs to do
substantial rehabilitation or
when the
unit is taken off the market because of
um
and um
oh boy
conditions that
make the unit inhabitable so it's kind
of a um what they call a construct
constructive
eviction of the tenant
because they have to move
and in those instances the tenants
usually don't have any other place to go
so i fully support this bill and i hope
that you all will as well thank you
other comments representative wolper
uh thank you mr chairman uh i have to
say that
one of the things
maybe the only thing that we really
heard both sides testified to
during this hearing
i want to say disingenuously use
this
provision of the law
to avoid
the lengthy
process of normal eviction which only
that if that's true and both sides said
it was
then adopting this legislation will have
a
much larger effect
on the reduction
of available housing for renters
landlords and potential landlords from
entering the market
and
encourage them others
you know it just just
won't work it sounds good it won't work
thank you
representative horgan um
yes thank you the
um i
actually have the notes in front of me
of all the people came in and testified
and it was um
pretty much as you would expect
the new hampshire apartment association
was against it and the realtors against
and everybody else
recognized that this was a additional
protection for tenants who already
huge disadvantage in this seller's
market and
even the objections of the pro landlord
side were fairly muted because eviction
already is a difficult process that
takes a lot longer than the nominal time
which
it can be as little the nominal time
results seven days if this passes to be
60 days but it always takes a lot longer
than the nominal time and i um
i personally don't have a big big big
big problem with that um
and in this parenthetically um we always
say well we should be encouraging
landlords we'd be encouraged to build a
more rental property and we've rarely
have ever seen any bills at least in
this committee
that encourage rental property um
although
these bills relay that to go to other
committees and we actually was
a thing in the newspaper where there is
some initiative going forward through
joint fiscal which probably using
uh
one-time federal funds but i just feel a
little bit embarrassed that uh you know
we haven't
i just feel sorry a little bit left out
that we've never seen any bills in this
committee actually encouraging uh
people to build more property it's
always uh
that every time we do anything
particular
tenants it's uh but anyway i've said
enough about it but yeah i think uh
i think this bill uh will not harm the
landlords much you know do a little bit
to help the tenants anyway
thanks representative macbeth
thank you chair gordon and i wanted to
respond to something i'm not sure if i
heard my colleague correct i just wanted
to clarify and this is not legal advice
but the eviction process does take
longer than 30 days i think the initial
response window may be 30 days
but then there are
at least 30 more days maybe to get to
court 30 more days to correct i mean i'm
trying to look up right now on new
hampshire legally websites but it's i
think i did hear that testimony as well
and
the reason why both sides were saying
that
um sometimes if it happens
landlords would use the uh renovation or
sell
is you know
issue to get someone out it's because
it's a lot easier than the eviction
notice
representative mclean
thank you mr chair um
i'm very sympathetic to this bill in
many ways because uh when i was a young
couple with my wife living in new york
we went through this scenario
single income the rent goes from 950 to
1500 and we're out okay so but we have
to be careful that you know coming from
a place of compassion that we don't do
more harm
the the demand side in new hampshire
right now is super hot
but the struggle is really on the supply
side and actually we have done things in
this committee we've looked at the
housing appeals board we're going to
interim study the land use docket and
we're not approaching this problem in a
vacuum there are other agencies that are
attacking this as well but i think what
we have to do is we're in a very
delicate situation i don't think we
really want to upset anything we want to
give some of these initiatives an
opportunity to run for a little while
assess that and
bringing forth this kind of legislation
at this time may actually be
counterproductive
other questions or comments
i just i just want to say that you know
i've really been torn on a bill because
you know on its face you say well geez
you know
given our circumstances right now giving
what's the harm and but
then i look at what the purpose of it is
and
and the purpose is to say well people
need an additional 30 days because they
may have another they have more need to
relocate
but the other side of that having sat in
the court is judges right now have the
discretion when someone is when you
determine somebody should be evicted to
give them up to 90 days
and to make a determination of the
amount of time somebody actually needs
to relocate
and judges can do that today and it
seems to me what this bill is intending
to do
is take that discretion away from the
judge
and say
judge you have to give them another 30
days on top of the 90 days that you can
give them
and i think
and of course what we heard in the
testimony when we asked the question
about that was well judges aren't given
the 90 days they're only given the 30
days well i'm presuming they're giving
the time that they feel
that
the tenant needs in order to relocate or
they should be and if they aren't maybe
that's where the problem needs to be
addressed
not in the not in
taking away the discretion
but in
making sure that judges are
appropriately giving the people the time
that they need up to the 90 days that
they need so i guess when it came down
on the balance i thought that
the itl was probably the appropriate
recommendation
other comments
yes representative chase
thank you mr chair and actually i just
want to uh clarify with yours so are you
saying if this were to go through you
feel that the
the bill would take away from the judge
already being able to give 30 days i
mean 90 days and it would just say no
now the law is
no it would not take away from the judge
basically what you'd be doing is giving
the tenant 150 days
okay
thank you
up to 150 days depending on what the
anybody
else if not i think we could vote
for mr clerk
the end this is a on senate bill 217
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
on the motion of any expedient to
legislate house senate bill 217
representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes representative
welper bots representative alexander yes
representative lassells
yes
representative nodder yes representative
murder yes representative kelly
representative trottier
representative andrus yes representative
smith
representative woods no representative
oregon no representative lorenzo no
representative chase no
representative muse
no
representative langley no
representative macbeth no
representative page no
representative simpson no
mr chairman yes i have an eleven in the
affirmative attendant
representative lorenzo yes
and would that be odd to pass
i do
i mean i could pass i'm sorry
senate bill 222 an act permitting
licensing boards to conduct remote
meetings
okay
uh
just the one i have the amendment for
oh okay so i'm just moving uh thank you
mr chairman i'm moving expedient to
moved by representative wolper
inexpedient to legislate and seconded by
representative mclean
and would you like to address your
motion
when you find your notes no i don't need
the notes
so uh yeah mr chairman uh
so my first problem with this bill is i
don't like the idea at all of writing um
exceptions into the right to know law
the right to no law has applied to
everybody in the state
and
this is just an exception we have
another bill with another exception and
we have another bill that makes an
exception for the general court and i
don't think we should just be writing
exception after exception after
exception into the right to noah
the bill has other problems the way it's
constructed
so i just don't think we should be doing
it and
want to make it inexpedient to legislate
other comments or questions
thank you mr chairman um this is one as
as our distinguished clerk notes this is
one of a number of bills that we have
all
trying to do the same thing
these bills
come out of our culvert experience
in the covet experience when we were
able to have
when particularly
well when everyone
was able to have uh remote meetings
we found universally that many more
people in the public participated many
more people in the public understood
what
how complicated it is to run government
and it also made it possible for members
of boards commissions councils whatever
and i'm staying away here from the
general court
were able to participate
remotely with somewhat more ease than
they could this is particularly notable
because
we have a state that is
built longitudinally and most of the
population is in the south and many
people have long distances to travel
if
some of us had our way
we would address this the way we tried
to address it last year in a very
reasonable consistent way
not picking away bit by bit not looking
at one agency or one
one department
but really saying universally in the
state of new hampshire in order to
increase public participation and make
it easier for volunteers to work on
boards and commissions we would permit
with certain guidelines
uh distance participation i for example
think that the chair must be at a site
and there must be a physical sign and
there should be a certain number of
people there um
that is does not at the moment seem to
catch the attention and the enthusiasm
of a majority of of members and
we recognize this
i and a number of my colleagues will on
each of these bills not support itl not
because we think these bills are
wonderful but
barring the opportunity to address this
in a reasonable rational way
we pick at the little pieces
um i don't think there's any reason for
me to repeat
what i've just said on the two or three
or four subsequent bills that are all
the same
the same argument and so i just wanted
to make it now in the interests of time
and
save you all from boredom but that is
why i um
i would oppose the itl not that i think
this bill is anyone's
gift to the state
but because um
barred from doing something more
reasonable
we're just trying to pick away at it
thank you
yeah
i just do
uh yes mr chairman
representative wolper
so thank you and i have to agree totally
with my honorable colleague from durham
uh it would be way better if we could
find a real solution to this and we have
a bill
which we'll get to later and also i'm
going to recommend ito on that
[Laughter]
it comes that comes pretty close
to what we need for a solution
pretty close it's only got like three
significant flaws
these other bills have many more
right
and the problem is that the right to
know act is has has a lot of parts to it
and when you start playing with one part
it
doesn't fit anymore
and then i'm conflicting with other
parts
so that's why i'm voting against all
these bills
uh i'm hopeful that the
house bill 481 we passed and sent to the
senate will uh enact put in place the
ombudsman at the right general
commission recommended and will be a
major step toward resolving all of this
but for right now
seeing none mr clerk uh would you like
to take the role this is on senate bill
222 an act permitting licensing boards
to conduct remote meetings the motion is
a recommendation of inexpedient
legislation turn myself back on on the
information on on the information okay
are we ready on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate senate bill 222
representative mclean
yes representative silva yes
representative welper votes yes
representative alexander yes
representative lasalles yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes
representative kelly yes representative
trottier yes
representative andrus yes representative
smith no representative woods no
representative oregon no
representative delorenzo
representative chase no
representative muse
no representative langley no
representative macbeth no representative
page no
representative simpson no
mr chairman yes i have an 11 in the
so we will
we will be recommending inexpedient to
legislate and there will be a minority
report
of ought to pass
senate bill 243 an act permitting
transfer on death deeds for real
property
representative mclean do you have a
motion i make a motion of interim study
mr chair
and i'll second that motion
and is there
would you like to address your motion
yeah i mean i think uh
both sides on this bill
recognized that there was some value in
having
an alternate way to to transfer property
at death and that's indicated by the
fact that 29 states and the district of
columbia have already done this but this
particular legislation um has a lot of
gaps in it
and um
uh
there was
notification receipt disclaiming and
then a lot of testimony about undue
influence things of this nature
so for those reasons really i think
we've got to get together and clean up
the bill before we can go forward thank
you mr chair
yeah representative lorenzo i agree that
the bill needs more work
i think i was particularly um
surprised to see that
folks could do this type of deed
and
unwittingly
the beneficiary doesn't know anything
about it until the person passes away
and
with
that that you know transfer of the
property the
beneficiary ends up picking up all of
the encumbrances wrapped up into the
property which could cost them money and
could get them into a lot of trouble so
i agree thank you
we have a motion of
interim study this is on senate bill 243
and mr clerk would you like to take the
role
on the q on the question of uh
inexpedience so to legislate senate bill
no no no no interim study
inexplicable
my mouth is stuck on an expedient
okay on the question of
interim study
senate bill 243 representative mclean
yes representative sylvia yes
representative roberto t house
representative alexander yes
representative with cells yes
representative notter yes representative
yes representative kelly yes
representative trottier yes
representative andrus yes representative
smith yes representative woods yes
representative horrigan yes
representative di lorenzo yes
representative chase
representative muse yes representative
langley yes representative macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative simpson yes mr chairman
yes
i have it at 21 in affirmative zero in
the negative remove consent
does anybody have any objection if that
goes on the consent calendar
seeing none
senate bill 296 an act relative to
complaint procedures and cases before
the commission for human rights
representative mclean do you have a
motion make a motion of interim study
and is that seconded yes mr chair a
second seconded by representative
alexander so we have a motion pending on
296 of interim study and would you like
to address your motion yeah thank you mr
chair so i think that um everybody
agrees that all parties
in a claim before the human rights
commission
should have
their full due process rights um
but
the the supreme court has ruled that um
it is the claimant
that gets to choose the forum and i
think the the testimony that was most
compelling for me
in the public hearing was the fact that
all of the removal from the commission
to the um
to the superior court last year was done
by the respondent and not by the
claimant and that's not the case every
year um but the majority of the removal
is by the respondent so that that de
facto takes away
um
the right of the claimant essentially to
to choose the form
the reason i think that we have to look
at interim study
as opposed to just an ought to pass
motion on this
is because we heard testimony uh from uh
some of some of the attorneys for the
employers that we're talking about
five years to
a probable cause finding and as as the
chair said justice delayed is justice
denied so if you're a claimant before
the commission and you have to wait five
years you're basically
potentially under a lot of pressure from
your employer at that time waiting for
that to come forward and if you're
someone
and the claim is not legitimate and
you're actually innocent
you're under that cloud for five years
and
there's a lot of reputational damage
that can happen in that time so i really
think
before we go and we just remove take
away that right of removal we have got
to address
some of those issues
around the commission and i think this
is an opportunity to do that
this would be a real interim study
and i would be excited to work on it
with a bipartisan group and i hope you
other comments representative macbeth
thank you chair gordon um i agree with
representative mclean i think that there
are really some issues here that were
good that were brought forward and um
but some work on it would be the best so
we can support interim study on that
thank you
other comments
representative lorenzo thank you mister
and um
no reflection on the executive director
of the human rights commission i think
she's doing a fabulous job with what she
has to work with
um
but
i feel like the commission is a paper
tiger and it should be revamped or
absorbed by the ag office a study of
best practices from other states for
instance maine or massachusetts
could be warranted i also think the
concept of a volunteer board making
critical decisions about lies and
livelihoods is perhaps mistaken
the current board may be okay but but
commission by design is left open to the
governor appointing
people who may not be up to the
challenge
that defeats the purpose and intent of
having a viable transparent and robust
commission thank you
thank you for your comments anyone else
wish to comment represent mclean
yeah and i just want to reiterate um
representative renzo's comments that
again my comments were no reflection on
the director of the human rights
commission who gave excellent testimony
just to add to
add to the issue of and again
not focus at the director but at the
structure of the human rights commission
i i
i just think it's
abominable
that we should find ourselves in
circumstances where it takes
five years to resolve these types of
complaints i think we should be
embarrassed by that
frankly and
the the other
the other one thing that i'd add to it
is
uh clearly that if we were to pass this
legislation it would mean more work for
the commission
without any additional resources
to address that work and just extend
those time frames and it which doesn't
make any sense so i i agree there needs
to be a fix and it needs to be a fix for
the commission and hopefully we can do
so you know when i'll wait till i get a
we have before us a motion it's a motion
on senate bill 296
to uh recommend interim study
and mr clerk would you be willing to
take the role
on the motion of interim study for
senate bill
296 representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes representative
walpervolt yes representative alexander
yes representative with cells yes
representative notter yes representative
yes representative kelly yes
representative trottier yes
representative andres yes representative
smith
yes representative woods yes
representative horrigan no
representative lorenzo yes
representative chase
representative muse yes representative
langley yeah representative macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
simpson yes represent mr chairman yes i
have been 20 in the affirmative one in
the negative move
consent does anybody have an objection
to consent no i'm fine with consent i
would i would have preferred passing the
bill but i'm happy interim study i'll
let that go yes
thank you representative horrigan
so we've adopted the recommendation on
296 of interim study and we'll buy a
vote of 20 to 1 and we'll put that on
the consent calendar
senate bill 297 an act relative to
obtaining out-of-state discovery and
testimony
and i'd make a motion about to pass on
that
kurt would you mind seconding that i
i've
senate bill 297 is a very simple bill i
heard the bill
that right now
if you want to do or take
uh a deposition from another
jurisdiction it requires to support the
superior court to appoint
a commissioner in order to do that and
what this bill
basically does is allow
for that deposition to be taken from a
foreign jurisdiction according to the
laws of that jurisdiction without having
to appoint a commissioner
and it's typically of what other states
do
and it would be much more efficient
process
and
certainly would recommend not to pass
seeing then i guess we can take a vote
this is uh this is on senate bill 297
with a motion of ought to pass
mr clerk
on the motion of ought to pass senate
bill 297 representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes representative
well provo ts representative alexander
yes representative lassells yes
representative notter yes representative
yes representative kelly yes
representative charlie here yes
representative andrus yes
representative smith yes
representative uh woods yes
representative horrigan yes
representative lorenzo yes
representative chase
representative muse yes representative
langley yes representative macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
simpson yes mr chairman yes i have it at
21 in the affirmative zero in the
negative move consent
anyone have any objection if we put that
on consent
seeing then i just note that we've
adopted a recommendation about to pass
on senate bill 297 by a vote of 21 to
nothing and it will appear on the
consent calendar
senate bill 301 an act relative to the
procedure for violations under the right
representative alexander do you have a
motion yes mr chair i move um ought to
pass
as amended and i move
amendment
um
2022-1526-h
oh
second
move by
representative alexander and seconded
by representative mclean
to adopt the recommendation about to
pass as an as amended with amendment
1526h
and would you like to address your
motion uh yes mr chair thank you um so
currently the
um
this this amendment is uh basically hb
481 which is in the senate right now
we have
um this bill the underlying bill would
address grievances under the right to no
law in the courts
but this judiciary committee has
kind of taken a position on how we want
to address grievances under the right to
know law by um
creating an uh right to know ombudsman
so um this this amendment would replace
the bill with um
h the text of hb 481 to just assert our
position that this is probably the best
way to go on the house side um and i
look forward to hopefully um having
conversations with the senate on the
best way to move forward on grievances
under the right to know law
on the amendment
can we do a hand count on the amendment
okay
so uh we have a motion before us and the
emotion itself at this point in time is
on the amendment and that's the adoption
of amendment
h
and
all those in
all those opposed please raise your hand
you've adopted the
20 to zero right we're missing one
person
so
we've adopted the amendment by 20 to
zero
and now we're
would you like us to uh
wait on on our
vote until your
thank you
on senate bill 301
we now have a motion of ought to pass as
amended with amendment 1526
and we do have our member back
and mr clerk would you and this is on
the recommendation about to pass as
amended
clerk would you take the role
on ought to pass with amendment
1526h on senate bill 301 representative
mclean yes representative sylvia i'm
representative walter baltias
representative alexander yes
representative lacelle's yes
representative norter
yes
representative merner yes
representative kelly
representative chartier yes
representative andres yes representative
smith yes representative woods yes
representative horrigan yes
representative lorenzo yes
representative chase
representative muse yes
representative langley yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
simpson yes
mr chairman yes i have it 20 in the
affirmative one in the negative and move
consent
well uh do you want to do a minority
21. so you've adopted the recommendation
about to pass as amendment with
amendment 1526h
on senate bill 301
and
we've done that by a vote of 20 to one
senate bill 302 an act establishing the
personal privacy protection act
representative mclean do you have a
motion
thank you mr chair mr chair um i would
uh
move uh ought to pass and put forward
i'll second that mr chairman okay moved
by representative mclean and seconded by
representative merner
with a motion of octopass as amended
with amendment one four four
three h and do you want to address your
motion
thank you mr chair so um
i think uh looking back at the public
hearing last week
there was you know broad support uh
amongst the committee uh for
maintaining donor privacy we people for
example on this committee that are
pro-life or pro-choice some might want
to give the planned parenthood some
might want to give to new hampshire
right to life and and that's their
business and they shouldn't be molested
for that but there were concerns uh that
were uh brought up um by various groups
including uh the charitable trust
with respect to concerns um about
transparency of the board uh concerns
with would this you know allow
certain charities to get away with scams
fraud charities
and even uh the lottery commission came
in with concerns about being able to
license for uh charitable gaming for
charity so
um
there were discussions with the various
stakeholders and an amendment was uh
sent over to myself and representative
gordon and you know being a good deputy
i
i filed it and what i'll do is i'll do
my best because there are many parts
because there were a lot of concerns
that were brought forth
in the public testimony so i'm going to
do my best to kind of march through the
various parts of the amendment and
chairman gordon you can always step in
to clarify as needed if i go off the
tracks
so the first thing is um if you look at
the original bill
um
go to page one line ten
so
the the the change the first change in
amendment uh 1443 h is just to address a
drafting error coming over from the
senate amendment
which basically says notwithstanding any
law and subject to paragraph 91
c colon 2. so that just is clarifying uh
the part of 91
that is relevant
then going on to uh page
two
um
page to
go to uh
line
anyone
so page 2 line 36 so this is this is in
the um
this is in the exemption section so
there's roman 5
but directly beneath that roman 5
you can see the addition of roman 6 in
which basically
gives
oversight function with the
administration of any government grant
program and that was requested by hhs
and if you go down
to line 16
right beneath that
so i have on a
b and c
the next thing is with respect to the
board of directors transparency you're
going to be
adding a d
section and that section is
going to say as you can see in the
amendment a request by the attorney
general for the identity of any director
officer incorporator or registered agent
of a non-profit organization
et cetera et cetera
basically you know
just
allowing the charitable trust to do his
job allowing the investigation of shams
sham charities uh anything of that
nature
then directly
beneath that
you're going to introduce roman 3
and that basically addresses the
concerns of the lottery commission with
respect to charitable gaming
you know nothing in the chapter shall
apply to request a lottery commission
pursuant to the authority under et
cetera et cetera for the purposes of
licensing or regulation of charitable
gaming activities
um and so
that
basically addresses the concern that was
brought forth by the lottery commission
so um and
the last thing
is
with respect to the penalty phase
the um
the misdemeanor
and imprisonment
portion that is removed
so
that basically
is
there's a lot of working parts to that
amendment
so um but based on the public testimony
that we heard looking at the hhs
concerns the ag concerns lottery
commissions concerns
we think that this amendment has
basically addressed the bulk of that and
mr chair did you have anything to add to
that or
no other than my major concern i think
was the testimony from the ag's office
and my concern was
because everybody that testified
testified
i think
that
the names of donors shouldn't be
released and i think generally i can
agree with that
but it went further than that it talked
about
not disclosing the names of any
volunteers and
certainly the
board members of most of these
charitable organizations are volunteers
and so if you
if the charitable trust
unit has responsibility for
making sure that
board members are carrying out their
fiduciary duties and doing it properly
they need to have the names of board
members and i wanted to make sure that
they would be able to have access to
that more than anything else
and i didn't think that the original
bill did that
i think
the language in here at least was
intended
to address that particular the portion
of the of this amendment was intended to
address that to
so like i said so i think everybody
agrees donor privacy is an important
issue that should be addressed and
hopefully
with the amendment and the changes to
address those concerns i hope that the
committee will support the amendment and
a motion of ought to pass as amended
representative lorenzo mr chairman just
following up on
what you had said about board members
as volunteers being identified are so am
i to think that
board members are providing in-kind
services
which you know ordinarily could be
translated into dollar amounts but does
that
compel you to think that way
it's typical for
for
charitable organizations 501 c 3
organizations to have board members that
aren't paid
and so
that would make them in effect
volunteers or providing their services
as a board member as a volunteer
representative horrigan
yes i'm i'm sure this amendment is going
to pass it does uh
as i said it does address a number of
objections that were raised the the bill
but i think i'm personally still going
to vote no on it because i think the
entire
bill is unnecessary so i think the uh
there are the protections that are in
place are
are sufficient and
of course organizations can only
the 501c3 is uh accompanied by you know
a political action committee or a
similar uh thing for doing um
or a similar entity for doing certain
types of uh the activities of the
organizations i i think this is
unnecessary it's also uh
primarily a
this is primarily about the federal tax
code and of course um so that's not
really a state concern since we don't
even
have a state income tax so i'm going to
say so i'm just so i'm just going to be
a naysayer and vote no on the amendment
although i do appreciate the work they
went into and necessarily does make
a bill that i'm not crazy about less
objectionable but
thanks
other
i think the amendment is
is a significant improvement over a very
bad bill
i intend to vote for the amendment um
and the off chance
that
the bill actually passes i would at
least like it to be
less bad
and i see that as my obligation to the
committee and to the
citizens of the state
i'd like to point out that although this
does talk about
501 c of the internal revenue code
it does not
talk about any of the um subparts of 501
c for example three
which many of us are familiar with and
you know i've already mentioned you know
the durham historic association and i'm
pleased to report that i have filed the
annual report and paid my 75 dollars
um
so you know
don't worry about me i'm in good shape
um and and most are most
most are but this includes all the other
subparts of 501c and that includes um
those uh
organizations which have formed
ostensibly
under the overarching of 501 c but then
go on to do other kinds of things
that
are legal as long as they're reported
when people
um
function in tax-exempt organizations
there is no free lunch
the citizens of the state in this case
or of the country are paying
because
those organizations are not paying
their taxes and we make a judgment that
when organizations are working for the
public good
they should be freed from tax taxation
responsibilities
and that is is a
a laudable
um
a laudable position
but other other subparts under 501c are
involved in
in activities which aren't charitable
and educational
and move much more towards the partisan
political
and
and i believe that the rest of us
shouldn't be
paying for their operation because
they're not paying taxes
um
i think this is not a question of a
personal privacy act
um i think it's a question of it's been
proposed and argued by people trying to
protect their own
interests which might not necessarily be
for the public good so i have intentions
to vote for the amendment
and um
and i i would be thrilled if you would
all then vote against the bill but just
in case at least the amendment would
make this a little
less bad thank you
thank you very much for your comments
other questions
comments
okay
okay we're going to be voting on the
amendment
1443 h
i guess we can do a show of hands unless
somebody prefers to have a role
okay
all those in favor raise your hands and
keep it up until representative wilper
counts
okay so you've adopted amendment 1443 h
by a vote of
20 and the affirmative one in the
negative
now we're
be now we will be addressing
microphone
thank you
um
chair gordon and thank you
representative mclean for your amendment
because i i do believe it
um improves the bill i'm i'm hoping that
i could con
some of you maybe to go with interim
study because there are things that need
to be changed and even this amendment
which i appreciate we got that last
night um there's there's some things
that i would i would like to add to it
um
one being the attorney general's right
to enforce the um political contribution
um that section i think was 447 but
just four brief points i mean we've
heard that this really is a problem
i mean it's a bill looking to solve a
problem that doesn't exist we heard from
the there's testimony that there's been
no chilling effect on the contributions
in new hampshire to non-profits and
charitable organizations actually last
year was the largest year that they
could remember
number two
this doesn't just go to charitable
organizations it's to any non-profit and
so that's significant because those are
um you know very pointed toward
different issues and policies
um
the other
really thing is this bill breaches the
underlying principle of why it was
established that nonprofits would get
the tax exemption and that their donors
would um and it was the transparency
that they would be able to prove that
these um funds were going for public
good
and just since the the our hearing i
want to draw your attention to the
lieutenant governor of new york democrat
i believe who was um you know uh he's
been indicted by the fbi or the mid
charges brought forth and as i
understand it from the new york times
and again i'm you know i know the truth
of the press but um one of the big
issues was there was fifty thousand
dollars that he when he was the
comptroller of the state that he
directed toward a non-profit and then
that non-profit made contributions
political contributions to his campaign
which because
um they were a non-profit they could um
file more i mean provide more money than
just one person so that's one of the
illegal actions that i certainly would
hope
and we may be preventing our attorney
general from investigating or for others
from investigating and i'm also
concerned about and we heard testimony
regarding just the attorney general's
ability to do their job to get the
information that they need to certify
that these non-profits and charitable
organizations are indeed um you know
using the funds for
public benefit and whatever else their
audits need to find out so i really i
appreciate so much i think there are
significant things in your amendment
again i appreciate it but i would like
to look at it more and i if i could get
anyone to
not support the ought to pass with
amendment and go for interim study i
would certainly appreciate you joining
thank you mr chair um yes so
when i am not in the legislature i run a
small 501c3 so i wanted to let all of
you know that
and to say that i really appreciate the
amendment um
and that i'm i'm still not sure how this
how the amendment would affect a small
501c3 i don't know we heard testimony
from the center from nonprofits for
non-profits that there might be some
unintended consequences and so since i'm
not sure about that i'm leaning towards
my philosophical commitment to
transparency and will be voting against
representative walper
thank you mr chairman
the objections to this bill that
i've heard here
have largely to do with political
contributions although there are many
other 501 c sections
that don't deal with that but there is
that one and there is an entire body of
our law that deals with those
organizations that engage in political
activity
and
thank you
and their uh
activities
but
if there's ever a place
where privacy
is important
that's it
because
that's the most divisive part of our
society right now
so i'm supporting this bill and and i
just that
i think we're doing the right thing by
you ready to vote
here we have
a motion before us on senate bill 302
the motion has ought to pass his
amendment with amendment 1443-h
and
on the question
turn yourself on
on the question of octopass as amended
with amendment one four four three h
on senate bill 302 representative mclean
yes
representative sylvia yes representative
welper of ots representative alexander
yes representative lassells yes
representative
yes representative yes representative
kelly
representative trottier yes
representative andres yes representative
smith
representative woods no representative
oregon no
representative diorenzo no
representative chase
representative muse no representative
langley no representative macbeth no
representative page now representative
simpson
no
mr chairman yes i have an 11 in the
affirmative
10 in the negative
and that would be ito
okay so on senate bill 302 we've adopted
the recommendation about to pass as
amended with
amendment 1443 h
by a vote of 11 to 10 and there will be
a minority report done by representative
mcfadden
senate bill 339 an act relative to
meetings of boards and commissions in
the department of safety
i make a motion that we itl this bill
moved by
representative andres second and
seconded by representative silvia
that
we recommend senate bill 339 in
expedient to legislate and represent
anderson would you like to address your
motion
i understand everybody's opinion in both
having
a possible remote meetings
my thing is
in the last year and a half i have
attended
many
zoo meetings
many live streamed meetings
and nobody nowhere
can guarantee
a hundred percent access
to the citizens on a public meeting
and i'll give you an example
i was attending school board meetings in
my school district
and because i couldn't wear a mask i was
in a separate room
live streamed the meeting
and twice the live stream did not work
and i had to go
stand in a hallway
and try to listen
to the school board meeting
which was very i mean it was not audible
at all
no citizen should have to do anything
like this
uh
i also look at it this way
whether we are
or appointed
when we take on
whatever we're doing
we know up front
that is going to be
public meetings
and every citizen in the state of new
hampshire
does not have access
to electronics i mean there's people
like my husband he knows how to turn on
the computer and get on the internet but
that's it and i mean there's nothing
against him but there's many people like
him and we just can't take 91a
and change everything
and not have public 100 percent public
comments
representative lorenzo mr chairman um
representative langley has an amendment
to
sb 339
should we vote on the amendment first
uh we would have to vote on the
amendment if she wants to offer that
amendment we can address the amendment
okay
mr chair the motion was italian yeah the
most i guess yeah and just in terms of
procedure i guess what we have to do is
vote on the
motion
that's pending
before
the amendment can be offered as an
yeah
the motion could be withdrawn if if they
uh
you could do that if you wanted to do
that as a courtesy but
i withdraw my motion to itl so that we
can entertain the motion
of the amendment
okay and
mike would you withdraw your second
thank you very much
thank you
representative langley would you make
like to make an alternative motion
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative aldridge and
representative sylvia for withdrawing
your emotion your
emotions i'd like to move that we bring
forward an amendment
number one five four two h which is
going around now
i apologize for it being this late but
with the recommendation that the bill
okay
and would you want to address your
amendment yes i would
um i think as we heard testimony um
there were lots of people that weren't
able primarily from the department of
safety weren't able uh to necessarily
attend meetings uh particularly during
covid
and to your point representative andrews
i'm hoping that this amendment gives
us an alternative to the situation you
described at the school board
if you look at um starting with line 19
the requirement has changed to
require a
physical location
for a meeting where members can attend
in person
while virtually attending access she'll
be provided to those who are unable to
travel as well as the public and where a
minimum of one quarter of the board and
commission members shall be required to
be at the physical location so it would
give the flexibility of anybody
conducting a meeting the opportunity to
have people both physically present and
watching a meeting virtually or
participating virtually
the other addition
that's included in this amendment is the
inclusion in line eight of the rare
disease advisory council of the
department of health and human services
and that was primarily because those
the members of that council had a lot of
disabilities and impairments that
prevented them from attending physically
and we wanted again to have them have
the opportunity
to present a meeting that offered
both choices
either going on a regular participating
physically or watching it virtually so
with the amendment of number 15 42h
okay comments
[Music]
no joe
uh excuse me representative alexander
thank you uh mr chairman um
i have a question of the chair and maybe
a question of my friend of mine from
manchester um if the house has already
taken position on the specifically the
rare disease advisory council
um not being able to meet remotely would
that part of the amendment
be something that's allowed to be
introduced if we've already taken a
position that they are not allowed to
because i remember just just for the
committee like we we voted
to itl a bill recently that would allow
the rare disease
yeah
that's and that's already gone through
the house
yeah
i guess i don't know the answer to that
i guess maybe then you answer the
question me just pointing out that the
committee has already taken a position
on this
um one of these specific points in the
amendment thank you thank you
represent macbeth yeah so i actually
don't know either but it seems to me
that
this amendment
the other bill was different it didn't
have a presiding officer it didn't
require a physical
place and it didn't require that a
quarter of the membership be present
so it is i i would argue that it was
distinguished enough that it could be
considered
um
right
yes
i still don't know but i think we're
going to move forward with the bill in
any event
yeah mike as representative sylvia
excuse me
thank you mr chair and i just say that
uh i i think this uh kind of shotgun
approach to various different exceptions
to 91a is a poor policy i think
91a should apply
across all boards and commissions
and
i just remind folks that
we really
want to provide
public access
to
physical locations in particular
and as part of their regressive
grievance
if if
there was an unfortunate situation
during the pandemic where folks
felt they did not have access to
the gentleman in the corner office
and
chose to visit his home i don't think
that's an appropriate thing and i don't
think that we should set a policy that
would essentially encourage that sort of
thing so let's keep public meetings in
public places
and
not have uh
people's private spaces invaded and i
vote against this uh amendment and then
and then against the bill
i am actually going to take a little bit
different position i think than
represent silvia
with a in essence the same conclusion
but
i think the amendment makes an
improvement
to the bill i don't have any doubt with
that so i think i could support the
amendment itself
but the underlying bill i can't support
it sort of goes back to the way
representative smith approached a
different
prior bill
yes
the amendment may make it better it does
make the
i really had
difficulty in this particular bill and
particularly with the testimony that we
heard because
the testimony i heard
uh from
at least one of the witnesses was
hey
look at the time i'm losing having to
drive to concord
from hanover and the time i lose driving
back when you know i could be seeing
clients or billing
clients for that time i'm losing money
coming to concord well i'm not sure
that's a good reason
to
do this and
it seems to me that if you make the if
you make the commitment if somebody
approaches you and says we want you to
be a member of a board that
you accept the responsibility become a
member of the board and that means
attending the meetings
and not to accept your responsibilities
and then say well no
i really don't want to have to do that
so
i'm going to vote against the bill
because i think it should be itl but i
can i can vote for your amendment
representative
yes well i agree that this scattershot
approaches poor policy but it's even
but
obviously the political will and
consensus doesn't exist
this time to come up with a global
policy even though what we did with the
emergency order
generally functioned
surprisingly surprisingly well
considered it was
considered
it was like devised on short notice
without a whole lot of
field testing for it but um so i think
but these three three um these
three boards have been according to the
testimony here have been pretty much
shut down for the last two years and
they're um
they're important especially given um
given the pandemic which is still going
on um
so i think uh i think even though it's
not
maybe poor policy of even worse policy
not to accommodate these boards and
certainly
no matter what we do even if we go back
even when we have all physical locations
not all meetings we're at a place that
everybody can get to um even though
they're all
they're not all held at times that are
convenient for for everyone
um
and
sometimes they held in places that not
everybody feels safe
um safe going to so i think that's an
unavoidable problem and then um
and uh
you know the debate is ongoing and i
think it's um
being driven by you know
anyway but it's being driven probably by
a vocal minority but um even
but focal minorities uh deserve to be
listened to too so anyway i think
we should pass this amendment and
pass this bill in order to empower these
boards to continue functioning because
they're very essential especially during
a time of pandemic so i would
i would say uh i would say so i'll vote
for the amendment and for the bill even
though
this doesn't solve the
bigger problem which will take us
okay any other comments yep
representative chase
thank you mr chair and i did want to
just comment on
what dr eric martin said who's the head
of trauma at
dartmouth hitchcock
and he had just said that how hard it is
to try to get especially the trauma of
people together because they do wear
many hats they're
in the er they're on the floor they're
just in many different areas and with
the shortage that we have right now in
our medical field that makes me nervous
to think that if we pull people out you
know that need to be at a meeting
because it's mandatory to be there and
then they are not on the floor they're
not where they're needed to help
people that are ill that that just
bothers me so i really the his testimony
was the one that got me going that i
thought that this was a good idea to be
able to allow
this with people that are wearing many
hats and trying to help our community
i'm going to vote for the amendment and
for the bill
thank you and representative woods did
you have your hand up
uh i'd just like to re uh like to
reiterate that in fact having the
experience on trying to get people to
serve on commissions that have high
quality
the fact of in person we've had the
experience that some people say i'd like
to serve
but if i could do it virtually so
one of the trade-offs is we are
sometimes eliminating so some of the
people that would contribute the best
thank you
yes representative mclean
thank you mr chair um i i think the
amendment is
a big improvement but to go back to some
of representative wolpers comments on an
earlier bill the the problem with the
amendment is that it it's still a
piecemeal approach and i think you know
to further draw on representative
wolper's comments we're engaged in an
iterative approach right now that is
getting us towards what we think the
final solution is going to be and i hope
that final solution will be somewhat
limited but
whatever it ends up being
we don't want to have a whole bunch of
different pieces lying out there in the
ether and so um i i i just think that
this this is the wrong approach for us
to be taking even though the amendment
does vastly improve the original bill
thank you mr chair
representative smith
i just have one very brief comment and
that is it is wonderful to hear so many
of you believe
that we should have
a consistent universal approach
and i look forward to the day when you
will in fact support such legislation
and you have had opportunities to do
thank you for your kind remark and
[Laughter]
mr chair i
i try to speak the truth thank you
yes representative simpson
thank you mr chair you all know how i
feel about the remote meetings um so
just real briefly i wanted to say um
how much i appreciated also
representative walpur's comments at the
beginning in our first bill
and just to say that i'll be voting for
the amendment and the bill
because i do feel there are some bodies
that are feeling that the lack of the
ability to solve this is a much more
urgent problem than other bodies thanks
thank you
anyone else
okay we're voting on the amendment
and this is an amendment amendment 1542
h
proposed by representative langley
and so
uh
we i guess we can have a show of hands
on that as well
this is all those in and this is on
senate bill 339 amendment 1542 h
yes
all those in favor of the amendment 1542
h please raise your hand
hand so it's at 11 to 10.
and so uh and this is with amendment
1542 h
can we talk about that
yeah you can talk about the underlying
bill if you aren't
uh thank you mr chairman so obviously i
voted against the amendment but that
isn't really why i'm voting against the
bill or the ought to pass is amended
because in my view the the bill has
issues
that
have been
uh bothersome in many cases and this is
just another
and i and i think the reason for that is
the desire of the public to participate
in one form or another
with
the desire of members
to participate
remotely
if we allow if we say members can do
this that's fine and we can let them do
that but when we say you have to allow
the public
now we have an entirely different
situation
because allowing the public
has the same drawbacks that howling
members does in terms of inability to
access
but it also creates the situation where
the public
could lose access for a short time
or
there that the uh and and for this
particular bill the notice has to be the
bill would have the meeting would have
to be noticed in that form
including the ways
of
uh
participating remotely and this bill
does not have that
so if you don't have if you don't have
to notify the public that they can
then the public won't be able to
and so the language in the bill really
any other comments before we vote
this is on senate bill 339
on a motion of ought to pass as amended
and mr clerk do you want to call the
role
on the motion of senate to pass as
amended with amendment 1542h on senate
bill 339 representative mclean
no
representative sylvia nope the clerk
votes no representative alexander no
representative la lascelles no
representative notter no
representative
no
representative kelly no
representative trottier
no
representative andres no representative
smith yes representative woods yes
representative horrigan yes
representative diorenzo
representative chase
representative muse yes
representative langley yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
simpson yes mr chairman no i have a 10
in the affirmative 11 in the negative
so he defeated the motion of ought to
pass as amended and
representative andrus do you want to
i make i make a motion that we itl house
is it senate bill house bill
house bill i'm sorry 339.
senator bill 339 second and seconded by
representative sylvia
if not this is a
uh
a vote on senate bill 339 on the motion
of inexpedient to
legislate
mr clerk
on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate senate bill 339 representative
mclean
yes
representative sylvia yes
the clerk votes yes representative
alexander yes representative
cells yes representative notter
representative
yes representative kelly
representative trottier yes
representative andres yes
representative smith
representative woods no representative
oregon no representative lorenzo no
representative chase
representative muse no
representative langley no representative
macbeth
representative page no representative
simpson no
mr chairman yes i have 11 in the
affirmative 10 and negative
okay you've adopted the recommendation
on senate bill
339 of inexpedient to legislate will
representative simpson you want to do a
representative langley would you like to
and that would be a motion about to pass
okay
moving on to senate bill and so as a
final result on senate bill 339 we've
adopted the recommendation of been
expedient to legislate and they'll be
by a vote of 11 to 10
and there'll be a minority report by
representative langley about to pass as
amended senate bill 344
an act relative to electronic
participation requirements of meetings
open to the public under the right to no
law seems like a familiar subject
this isn't on the notice 344 oh my
goodness it's not on the list
no i mean i think the rules will allow
us to do it anyway but well
yeah let me check the calendar thank you
uh
hey thank you i understand
senate bill
act relative to the electronic
participation requirements the meetings
opened to the public under the right to
are you making a motion thank you mr
chairman i would move in expedient to
legislate on senate bill 344
and is there a second second seconded by
representative sylvia
and representative wooper you want to
so this is the best shot yet
and it only has a few
things that are bothersome to me i may
can't
remember so
so part of the problem and perhaps the
biggest problem is on line 30 of page
one
if the public party is notified during
the meeting that the public is unable to
gain electronic access the meeting shall
be adjourned until the public is able to
access
adjournment under this condition
can be devastating to the boards
because they have a hard and a hard
enough time already
scheduling their meetings
so to have to adjourn because of a
technical problem where the public can't
access
is a real is a real problem for the
board
and again let's come back to where i
talk about conflating the board and the
public
so
so that's a real issue for me right here
that would that alone would be enough
for me to vote against this board
so it's got a lot of good things it
requires the physical location and does
something to address the quorum
requirements
and at the moment i am vacant there's
two other reasons why i don't
i oppose this bill but we'll just leave
comments
represent mclean
thank you mr chair um and i agree with
representative wolper as i said this is
this is an iterative process and this
this is i think getting us closer and at
least it's not piecemeal but there are a
couple of things that i really did have
uh concerns about with the bill and one
of them was with the
the what does reasonably practical mean
and
when we had the counselor from lebanon
come in she was saying well i would hope
that that would be interpreted in the
most restrictive way so if we had
somebody with knee surgery or something
like that and then we had uh someone
representing the counties come up to
testify
and they said well
we're seeing it completely differently
in terms of you know if there are
schedule conflicts people have busy
schedules etc
so there's
real difference of opinion in terms of
what that means but even more important
for me is is the fact that the this
thing kicks off you know when the
legislative body
authorizes it to be so and i think that
works great as i mentioned in the public
hearing for the town of litchfield which
is one of the towns i represent because
the people of litchfield will have a say
we think this works for us
but if you're in one of the the 13
cities in the state and i'm in
manchester essentially i'm not going to
have that because the legislative body
and the governing body are the same and
so the people in manchester really
aren't going to have that say
um and really it's just going to be
the the legislative body says yeah we
think this is good and that's because
they're identical and so i really think
you're disenfranchising the the folks in
the cities that that don't necessarily
have a town hall or sb2 former
government so these are the reasons i
think the bill is getting closer but i
represent
sylvia thank you mr chairman uh
so
you uh
representative mclean just hit on uh
reminded me of uh one of the
really large problems with this uh the
legislative body
of a political subdivision may vote to
authorize
um
that's
something less than clear
would it be a vote each time they want
to do
some sort of remote uh meeting would it
be an annual vote for a
town
meeting
would that vote happen at the town
meeting and be applied to the next town
meeting
this is uh
really unclear
and
that's certainly plenty of reason to
oppose this
we just had the hearing on this bill
yesterday so none of us have much time
to
think about it but it um
it is a step to a non wait something
other than a piecemeal solution and
actually
appears the uh coalition
in favor of in the senate was fair was
uh fairly broad so there are some fairly
conservative senators bucking um
bucking the other members of the party
and that doesn't uh happens more often
in the senate than the house but doesn't
happen too often so it's a positive
so it's positive positive trend and also
in terms of uh
the people and remote meetings when we
had the emergency order during the
pandemic um
participation in meetings um if anything
i think it maybe slightly went up at
least in my community in town meetings
this was
something that you know
the people actually
well they certainly were not actively
opposed to it it seemed to be quite
quite popular and of course you know not
everybody's
you know not everybody's computer
equipment works
but that's true even for in-person
meetings not everybody can get to every
meeting not every meeting is at a time
that's convenient for everyone or in a
place that
everyone can easily easily access so i
think
i mean there certainly are details in
this bill um that probably could be
looked at but i think rejecting it
i i think this is a uh
i think this is like a very huge step
forward so like um it would be it would
be a shame if something like this didn't
pass uh
fairly soon hopefully
so i would i would i would be opposed to
itling it right off the bat like this
thanks
comments
thank you there
there are many people who for one reason
or another uh can't get involved in
public service
um i myself had a job with a consulting
firm
it took me
60 hours a week
in a typical week and really left almost
no room
to do any of the kind of public service
work that i really would have liked to
have done
i think a lot of people who are not
retired
are in that situation there are things
that people would like to do
to help to become more involved in their
community to become more involved in
decision making in their communities
i see bills like this as a way to do
that and and i think
one of the good things that came out of
kovit if there if there were any good
things at all
was the fact that we all had a learning
experience around the fact that while
there are bugs with the technology
periodically
um overall it did allow more people to
participate in the process
um
and uh and a lot of people really
welcome that process and i think that
there are a lot of people right now
uh who are missing it
uh in my community in portsmouth it's
always a little bit of a struggle to
find as many volunteers as we need
especially qualified volunteers for
people to serve on our various boards
and commissions
this is something we can do to make it
easier
and the other thing that i'd like to
remind folks of too is
this was a huge benefit for people who
have mobility issues so not just young
people who are working
but people for one reason or another who
have problems getting up some of the
stairs of our public buildings who have
problems
getting into some of those rooms
problems with just transportation back
and forth and and so effectively when
we're not doing things like this i think
one of the things that we have to
realize
is that we are shutting people out of
the process
and these people are citizens too and
this is something that we need to keep
in mind
thanks
thank you
yes senator page representative page
thanks for the promotion thank you mr
chair
um i'm new so
this is my freshman
term as a rep but
i've yet to see and i'm respectful to
the piecemeal arguments about perhaps
the
cutting away exclusions swallows up the
rule
but we seem to identify that this is not
that
um
i've yet in my short tenure here i've
yet to see a perfect bill
but i've seen a lot of pretty darn good
bills
and i think this is one of those
i hear from folks back in exeter where
i'm from
elected officials and the public
begging for ways to keep this going
because they found
that they were able to access meetings
so under the pretty darn good bill
standard i think it passes
thank you
anyone else
representative chase
thank you just to comment
i agree i think this is the best we have
so far and i just want to say on a
personal basis i'm involved with a lot
of childhood cancer survivorship
studies and i was able to do a lot of
access and be involved in a lot of
things that were across country that i
never would have been able to afford to
fly out to california to be part of a
group and on a
a panel discussion so i think this is
great yes we're all going to have issues
but all in all this is the best way i
see to allow the public to have the
access for all of the reasons that david
pointed out
and my own experience thank you thank
you representative lorenzo thank you mr
chair i just want to talk about my own
experience and
my volunteer work i serve on the
board of the rotten ham nutritions meals
on wheels program and we've been meeting
virtually and it's been really really
great to be able to do that i also serve
on the rockingham county executive
committee and we have had virtual
meetings
and that's been very successful for me
in the executive committee thank you
representative langley do you want to be
heard
thank you mr speaker
i just wanted to comment a lot of people
have talked this morning about
doing this as a piecemeal kind of
legislation and i would agree that we've
done that and and i also would agree
with those that represented this as
probably the best effort that we've had
this far but i guess when i think about
doing something this innovative and for
us
video
access to public public meetings is a
new thing and it's happened as a result
of covid i don't think we can expect to
have it perfect i think we need to start
someplace and take the best of what we
have and to build on it from there and
and to decide that perhaps it's not
exactly what we want but we know that
it's going to get us to where we want to
go
and then if i just might add from a
personal perspective
um those of you obviously you know that
i'm in a chair and i was late this
morning and i was late this morning
because i could not get my vn door to
close it's automatic and every once in a
while it has a mind of its own and it
just keeps going back and forth
i just say the story because if i had
had public access i would have been able
to turn around go back in the house
turned on my computer and had access to
this meeting not be stressed not be
frazzled because i knew i was going to
be late and i knew that i had an
amendment to bring forward so i think it
provides opportunities that
we don't always think about and i think
it's a place to start and i think it's
very important that we get started
comments representative wolper are you
waiting i'm waiting yes yeah
representative oregon um
and yes what happened to
reverend langley applies even to people
who are what they call temporary
able-bodied like myself and
brethren mckinney were
late for meeting last week because my my
tire blew you know so i
i'm not in a i'm not in a wheelchair i
get around pretty well i get around very
well by myself but still like
something
something happened and thank you very
much everybody cooper very much to
accommodate us and we're extremely
grateful but that's uh
those type of things um those type of
things
happened even before we had virtual
meetings you know that's the fact of
life that not everybody
you know things happen to make it hard
for people to get to meetings um so i
think the objections raised about
computer problems are in many cases the
same thing as you know sometimes
people's computers don't work sometimes
people's tires blow and um
so
i think um on balance having
hybrid meetings um makes it easier for
people to uh makes it easier for members
of the public and for members of the
bodies to attend so i think this is a
this is a good bill it might
it might indeed need a amendment to
change adjourned to recessed but um i
say this is an excellent bill and i
think certainly
itlling it is like a premature and not a
representative wolfer
thank you mr chairman so this
conversation that we've just had
underscores
something that i've said over and over
and i said it at the beginning of the
discussion of this bill
that we conflate
the
operation of our 91a
and public access
it does not say
anything about how that's achieved
because it wasn't written
in the age of hybrid meetings
but there is no reason why
the members cannot participate
remotely and the public not have
electronic access
that there is no reason why that
situation has to can can't occur
at the same time there's no reason why
the public can't have
electronic access
right now just like they have access to
this meeting that we're in
they have no ability to speak
but they can observe
and they can follow what's going on
and hear and and they can watch their
public servants and actions which is the
essence of why we have public meetings
so that situation the access for the
public
is not a concern
of 91a
unless
you go to a
pretty much totally remote meeting
and that's what any but it creates a lot
of problems when you write the bills
because to allow large numbers of people
access
and to allow them and particularly
the opportunity to participate by asking
questions or making comments
is a much more difficult
task
than allowing them to observe and to
listen
so
there you have that
until we sort that out and i personally
would prefer if we just wrote a bill
didn't even talk to the public
it just said you can have remote
meetings as long as you go a number of
people when you notice it and you have a
regular public meeting but some people
can participate remotely i'd be a lot
happier to see that
because it would be easier to do
for everybody and when we start saying
things like you have to allow the public
to participate we run into
money miller issues with broadband and
cost and ability of rsa 2088 on
unfunded mandates and things like that
so we're close
to being able to do it for the boards
and i'm frankly very hopeful that we are
we have this done within the next year
but this bill was not that
and the objections that i i believe i
believe are valid and strong enough to
vote against it
thank you
okay
representative macbeth
so i just have a question if this bill
is close are you is interim studies
something that you would
if they're just a few changes would you
consider doing that so that we could
work on it and get it done i mean
because i do sense this urgency as well
amongst
having having already committed to serve
on one interim study committee from this
committee this year
i mean i would like to say yes to that
so is it your understanding though that
if you were to support interim study
that you would have to be a member of
that study committee
it's my understanding that i would not
support interim study any other way yes
okay thank you
what if we had all the meetings
virtually
okay
this is senate bill 344.
now they have a motion pending the
motion is inexpedient to legislate
and
all right on the motion of inexpedient
to legislate senate bill 344
representative mclean
yes
representative sylvia
the motion was itl so yes
representative well for both gs
representative alexander yes
representative cells yes representative
notter yes
representative murder yes
representative kelly
representative trottier yes
representative andrus yes representative
smith
representative woods no
representative horrigan
no
representative lorenzo
representative chase
representative muse
no
representative langley no
representative macbeth no
representative page no representative
simpson no mr chairman yes i have it all
i've been in the affirmative tenant
negative
you've voted
11 to 10
to make the recommendation expedient to
legislate on senate bill 344 is a
yeah i need to know who's going to do a
study
yep
so minority report will be done by
representative macbeth with a
recommendation of interim study i think
if we just
took 15 minutes would be a good idea
and
come back here at quarter past so we can
one more i get
representative langley's amendment
we're losing your audience
yes
attention
okay
i
sure
okay
foreign
yep
that's probably what that's already the
problem
so they're just changing where the money
comes from
oh
foreign
french
is
okay
from
um
we'll call the house judiciary committee
back to order
our next item of business this morning
is
senate bill 375 an act relative to
requirements for charitable
organizations
representative alexander do you have
a motion i i do mr chair and i hope this
is one that everybody can agree with but
i make a motion of ought to pass on
senate bill 375
i would second that motion
and would you like to address your
motion um sure mr chair um so this bill
um would ensure that charities are
protected from burdensome or onerous
filing requirements that are not
authorized under existing state or
federal law so currently um some some
charitable organizations are being
required to file multiple duplicative um
insensitive reports with local officials
and it's often exceeding current federal
and state requirements so
this job this bill does a good job
protecting the integrity of non-profits
in new hampshire but safeguard but put
safeguards in place that will provide
appropriate balance between
accountability
and reliability for all um charitable
organizations so i really hope that the
committee would agree with me thank you
comments
seeing none
mr clerk we have a motion on senate bill
375 the motion is ought to pass
and
mr clerk you could call the roll
on the motion
on the motion of ought to pass senate
bill 375 representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes court votes
yes representative alexander yes
representative michelle yes
representative
yes representative yes representative
kelly yes representative trottier
yes
representative andrus yes representative
smith
representative woods yes representative
oregon yes representative lorenzo yes
representative chase yes representative
muse yes representative langley yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative simpson
yes
mr chairman yes i have a 21-0 move
consent
any objection to being placed on the
consent calendar
seeing none
we have
voted that
senate bill 375 be recommended as ought
to pass by a vote of 21 to nothing and
we'll put it on the consent calendar
senate bill 388 an act relative to
availability of information or records
relating to the enhanced 9-1-1 system
representative wolper
you
thank you mr chairman mr chairman uh
i'd like to uh bring forward amendment
uh 15338 which was handed around earlier
this morning and move on to pass with
that amendment
i second that mr chair
moved by representative wolper and
seconded by representative alexander
that
we make a recommendation about to pass
as amended with amendment 1553-h
and would you like to address your
amendment i thank you mr chairman uh
so
the the point of this amendment what
drove this amendment is the roman three
that in romans 3 that you see
are bolded at the bottom of it and it
says to the insurance department which
is what what the bill is about in
connection with ongoing criminal
related to insurance fraud
oh
it's not isn't it no
no this is the same as the original bill
miss chairman
yes uh this uh amendment doesn't seem to
do what was discussed uh
during our caucus
uh is it possible does is there any
deadline on this
bill that is pressing
we do not have a pressing deadline
i'm
uncomfortable with the original bill as
it was uh submitted here and
if possible
i would rather take this up in the
um
so
yeah go go ahead representative open so
just so everyone knows what's going on
here
the intent of this amendment was and
remains
to narrow
and the department actually said
that they wanted information about the
nature and time of calls
and that's what we wanted i intended and
what i sent to ols to add into that
roman numeral three
in the process of doing that
well they didn't do it they didn't do
any of it oh they did
did they
where's the one two three yeah okay on
on line six
the current built law says rsa 91a
regardless of the use of sus information
under paragraphs one or two
or n2 yeah it must be one or two one two
since we're adding three
they did i guess so it says or three
right
so that part of it is good but but they
did not include the narrowing of roman
three under
and that's what the problem my problem
with this is that
i think this language is too broad right
now and especially since we're dealing
with e-911 data
it needs to be as narrow and
well i think we can um
we we have some alt since this isn't
what was intended
unless somebody ultimately makes an
alternative recommendation we could
we could vote down
your
uh your motion today or you could
withdraw your motion today
and we could recess to a later date
for executive session
the other possibility is if there
is an alternative motion one of the
things that we could do is potentially
have a
been expedient to legislate or ought to
pass if somebody felt that was
appropriate or
another motion of
interim study
which might be a
possibility i know that there were
or have been a number of concerns
expressed
which is what gave rise to your
amendment to begin with representative
alexander thank you mr chair um
in in deferring with my friend i i want
to throw it out there would a floor
amendment be okay yeah i'll agree on
that and we vote ought to pass and offer
a floor amendment and we
do it on a bipartisan if i were to uh
that's right so so
the what what's existing up on line six
needs to happen
otherwise
the roman three won't have any real
force
so we could adopt this amendment the way
it is
and i can introduce a four amendment
and
representative alexander alluded if we
can do that in some kind of bipartisan
manner that is we say
myself and maybe the senior member or a
couple of democrats sponsor the
floor amendment
we can talk to it in that way on the
floor
rep representative woods uh
another possibility we health and human
services met on tuesday we stayed till
nine o'clock
we had several amendments and ols
actually stayed until nine o'clock with
just that in mind
uh would there be a possibility that we
could recess this and have the
representative
see if ols uh because it seemed like it
would be a fairly quick redo and then do
this at the end of this session here
if if they're available uh they were
yeah i i would just um i would like it
to come out of the committee the way
instead of using the time in the house
session
it would be i would prefer us either
wait to have it done immediately today
because i know some of us may have plans
else you know until at nine o'clock i'm
sorry i can't stay that late but or if
there's since there's no time why don't
we just wait until our next executive
session
well we we were hoping to have this
would be this is our last bill so we
were hoping to have the executive
session done today if we could
um but
yes
representative smith
it is not uncommon
that in
using belt and suspenders that after a
committee
considers a bill
they realize that there's an additional
change that has to be made
i don't think it has to take up a lot of
time on the floor and i would
if
my hand was up
earlier to suggest that what we do is we
vote on on this amendment
we vote on the bill
and we agree
with that taking a vote
on a floor amendment
that can come in as the committee floor
amendment
and then that makes it possible
for us to finish our responsibilities
here and it makes it possible
for us to finish our response we have a
lot of time for this because
next thursday's session will only be the
the first committee bills
so it won't be till may 4th i guess
that it will come up but um i think
that's a
generally that's the most efficient way
i think the
the issue is with regard to the
amendment is that there was information
requested but
the way the current language is written
is just as representative wilbur said
it's just too broad give it too much
authority and it needed to be narrowed
down
because basically it gives them
if you read it it gives them access to
all of the information in 9-1-1 and when
specifically what they said is we only
want to know the nature and time of
calls and it should be limited just to
the nature and time of calls that they
have
and
so i think that would be what was
intended in the amendment and what we
would have to do as a floor amendment if
we all agree to that
so if i mean and i would be happy to um
have my name on the floor amendment um
with the clerk if that's the appropriate
way to do it
when okay
so would you want to
so uh
thank you mr chairman so
um i can forward all this to you so you
but the what what is lacking out of this
is in roman 3 my roman 3 says
to the insurance department
information on the nature and time of
calls
solely for the purpose of conducting an
ongoing criminal investigation related
to insurance fraud or other
insurance-related criminal activity
the insurance department shall not
release such shared data under rsa 91a
this is virtually the same language
that's in roman
two for the department of environmental
services
just
narrowly tailored to the insurance
department
okay and that was what that would be
what would be included in the floor
amendment that would be the fourth
amendment to replace mormon 3 with that
language
representative
mr chant thank you just a quick question
on the information i know you mentioned
the time and the nature of the incident
would that also
include the caller's information because
if they're doing a criminal
investigation into
fraud insurance fraud wouldn't they want
to speak with the caller who could be a
witness
um
it occurs to me
so
what they mean
[Music]
when they say the nature
of the call
is an interesting thing to parse
so i can't speak explicitly to that but
since they're doing a priority
investigation
and and i'll use the example of my house
burned down when i was a child the fire
was reported this is one of the things
they talked about the fire was reported
by a third party unknown to me for years
right
but the insurance department wanted
might want to know
who that person was
and if they have the nature of the call
and they know the approximate
i think they would be able to get that
or they would have it because it's most
often involved in fraud
they would be looking for the same
individual that's just committing the
fraud
thank you representative chair thank you
for taking my question i remember that
there was testimony the
are we still going to be able to give
them when they requested
a copy of that call because or you
saying they won't get a copy they'll
just get the nature and the number
because remember he said he was the
background information and one of those
calls is what tipped them off to that
there was fraud
i i would suggest that that's what they
mean when they say the nature of the
call
every part of it
but
but so you're not releasing the actual
transcripts you're just
i don't have a better answer than what
they asked for
and the nature and time is what they ask
for
that was from testimony directly from
the department this is what we're
looking for
they asked for the actual copy of the
um
they asked for the recording is my
understanding
well
i think there was uh
first of all
it only applies to criminal
investigations
and
so when
in those circumstances
they are able to get warrants they have
to go through the police to get warrants
but they can get warrants to actually
get the calls themselves if they need to
do that
but the question one of the questions is
the timing of the call
for example his example was
that he used was somebody who called
from the accident scene signing up for
thing is that it would be available just
would be two steps they first have to
get the nature and the time person and
then if they thought that was what they
wanted then they would go to law
enforcement and get the subpoena or
warrant if that's what it is for okay
it's available one way or the other to
them
it's it's available to law enforcement
today
and the issue as i understood it is
simply that
this investigator for the insurance
department is not a law enforcement
officer a sworn law enforcement officer
therefore he can't get a warrant to get
that information
and is not entitled the information
under the current law but he wants to
have access
to the time and the nature of the calls
probably to get probable cause
so from
a mechanism perspective we're gonna
octopass this but keep it off consent
so that
yep you'd have to
and then we'll bring the four amendment
and if it doesn't meet our expectations
presuming that if
the clerk and
representative smith co-sponsor it i'm
sure it'll meet our expectations
okay so
so i guess what we've decided to do is
go forward with approving the current
amendment and
do we want to approve the current
to ought to pass
do the bill out to pass
so
do you want to withdraw your motion with
regard to ought to pass as amended
uh mr chairman i'm happy to withdraw my
amendment and recreate the thing as a
good four amendment
okay so here we're drawing your motion
is ought to pass is amended and joey are
withdrawing as well as the second i'm
seconding the ought to pass motion and
you're seconding the optipass motion
made by kurt any other discussion on
that
okay this is on
the motion on senate bill 388 of ought
okay mr clerk do you want to take the
role
and we're doing this with the
understanding that there will be a floor
amendment
all right
on the motion about to pass senate bill
388 representative mclean yes
yes
[Laughter]
representative while progress
representative alexander yes
representative lasalles yes
representative notter yes
representative mirner yes
representative kelly yes representative
trottier yes representative andrus yes
representative smith yes
representative woods yes representative
oregon yes representative diorenzo yes
representative chase
representative muse
representative langley yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative simpson yes
representative mr chairman yes i have it
okay this is uh we just voted
that senate bill 388 be recommended
ought to pass
unamended
and that
we've made that vote on a
vote of 21 to nothing and this will not
be on the consent and i think we've done
it with the understanding that there
will be a floor amendment co-sponsored
by representative wolper and
moving on senate bill 392 an act
establishing a commission to study
insanity and restoration of competency
mr chavin i'd like to make a motion for
itl okay mr murder
representative murder
recommends
itl is that seconded i'll second it and
seconded by representative mclean
representative murder do you want to
address your motion yes we heard
testimony um
there is
stuff that needs to be done
but the executive branch has already put
together a working group
and i don't think there's any uh need
for the religious you know the
okay
yes representative otter or question
rather are the
the people that came to testify all the
different department heads
um are they aware of the executive
i
it was brought forth in testimony that
they had this and they would kind of
like want us to file something to
push them along to form a commission so
but
can i just
sure
i'm just questioning um because there
was the i'm questioning the testimony so
you all know about the executive council
going to be doing something because of
testimony that you heard in here or some
other source
executive because what what what i heard
and what we have is the two amendments
from i'm just want to make sure that
we're not confused there were the two
amendments from
senator sherman that he offered that
would have changed it from a legislative
committee
to an executive
working group
so we would have had there isn't
to my understanding it was just these
two amendments which would have changed
um
he was offering those for our senator
sherman was offering these for our
consideration there is no executive
study committee right now
representative mclean
yeah thank you um yeah i think so what
happened was the original bill was
setting up the commission
but they were sensitive to the fact that
we had a lot of commissions already and
there was a lot of weight in that area
so what they were saying is that the
solution was to and the amendments
addressed that to convert the commission
into a working group within the
executive branch and i i think what
representative verner was saying that if
the executive branch feels that that's
the best form
then they should
is it the place of the legislature to
tell the executive branch
how that working group should be
constituted and i think that was was
where we were going with it so you're
right it doesn't exist at this point
everybody agreed that there was definite
value in going back and re-examining the
definitions
looking at how do we have an effective
approach to restoring competency
but who is the legislature to tell the
executive branch what the
constituency of that executive group
representative smith
thank you thank you very much mr chair i
have a slightly different take on it
there already exists
um
a working group
um and the chair of the working group
indicated to us that she had been having
a great deal of difficulty
getting people to show up
getting people to participate um she
joked about having to provide donuts
her first mistake is that she should
have provided rugola but that's that's a
in fact
what she felt was that she
they needed the strong arm of the
legislature
to um
encourage the members
of her group to do what they in fact are
supposed to do
and um and that
to me is is a basic
is a basic problem
um
the idea that only when we tell the
members of the executive branch what to
do do they carry out their
responsibilities i have problems with
that idea
i also um
have
uh problems with the two issues being in
the same bill
in terms of the definition of insanity
which i know the wheels grind slowly but
i somehow think that we might want to
get into the 21st century
like the late 20th century even in terms
of a definition of insanity and i find
that very different and separate
from the issue of competency
which the group
presented
in terms of um
the for
the proposed um
hospital
and so i have problems with all of that
that having been said
the issue itself
is an important issue and barring um
other means of getting people to do what
they ought to be doing i would
reluctantly
very reluctantly vote ought to pass on
the bill
comments
i think i'd echo a lot of what
representative smith said only maybe
come to a different conclusion but
the
two different the bill first of all
deals with two entirely different issues
one is the definition of insanity the
other one is a process for determining
and addressing competency for people who
are standing trial and so they're two
separate issues but apparently one
commission to deal with these two
separate issues which i'm
not sure
why you need to have all those members
dealing with both of those issues
and and the person that impressed me was
dr bader who was here and the who was
the uh chief forensic officer for the
state
because what what she she was explaining
the need
for these things and clearly
there's a need to redefine insanity but
uh it seems to me that our
that the people that should be doing
that are within
state government today and you don't
need to get a group of 30 people
together in order to do that it just
doesn't seem reasonable to me
and then the second part is the issue of
competency and what
dr bader was saying was
we're the state i think we she
described us as 50th among the states in
terms of the way we address competency
and so
somebody can't stand trial they're not
competent to stand trial
we don't have a process in order to make
we have to make them competent within a
year to stand trial and we don't really
have any process to do that so basically
we're just letting people go
and
when they can't stand trial and which
doesn't make any sense and other states
have processes to do that because they
provide the services to do that and in
our state we don't provide services for
people to do that we say you're on your
own
get yourself competent
but
my impression was dr bader already knows
what needs to be done
we don't need a 30-member study
committee
to figure that out i think she already
knows what the state uh uh and there
ought to be a recommendation and it
seems to me that the whole purpose
behind this
committee
wasn't necessarily to
address the problem and figure out the
problem because i think she knows the
answer to the problem that
what it was is to provide the motivation
and the direction to get the funding to
do it
eventually
and
i just don't think we need to do that i
think they
should come forward and make that
recommendation and tell us what we need
to do as a state and and i think we
probably should fund it but
that's my thought but i'm going to vote
thank you
i just want to explain why i am going to
be joining you in your vote because i i
really was moved by the testimony and i
think that these are issues that are
really important to the state and to
our citizens and um
i i wish it was bifurcated i wish there
were two issues i wish that um i i do
support study committees but i want to
be sure that when we pull all of our you
know these like these appointed people
and our staff off of their work that
it's going to be for a good reason and
i'm not confident that this study
committee the way it's structured with
the charges is the way to go so
um i i do support changing the
definition i do support coming up with
ways to restore competency and having
programs and treatments for that but
this this is i'm not going to be
seeing none
we have this is on senate bill 392
we have a motion of inexpedient to
legislate mr clerk do you want to take
the role
on the question of voting senate bill
392 inexpedience and legislate
representative mccoy yes representative
sylvia yes
cork votes yes representative alexander
yes representative
yes representative notter yes
representative yes representative kelly
representative trottier yes
representative andres yes representative
smith
representative woods no
representative oregon no
representative diorenzo
no
representative muse
representative langley
yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes
oh sorry excuse me no sorry
yes it's no
[Laughter]
i love it when that happens
representative simpson
no
mr chairman
yes
i have one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen in the affirmative
and one two three four five six seven in
the negative
okay on senate bill 392
you have a doc that adopted the
recommendation of inexpending the
legislate by a vote of 14 to seven
representative simpson
otp
okay
and that moves us on to our last bill
today senate bill 399
an act relative to certain provisions of
the fetal life protection act requiring
representative wolper
thank you mr chairman i would move on to
pass on senate bill 399.
mr chairman dissecting that
representative smith would you like to
i second
okay
move by representative walper seconded
by representative smith
uh that the recommendation on three
senate bill 399 be ought to pass
is there any discussion uh thank you mr
chairman yeah we should we've done this
before with the position of the house uh
as expressed in house bill 1673
and has been concurred to in the senate
as house bill 1673.
is now before us in senate bill 399
so i just think we ought to say ought to
pass we haven't changed our mind we
see none
this is on a motion of ought to pass on
senate bill 399.
on the question of ought to pass senate
bill 399 representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes representative
walbervo ts representative alexander yes
representative lascelle
yes representative notter yes
representative merner yes representative
kelly yes representative charlier yes
representative andrus yes representative
smith
representative woods yes
representative horrigan yes
representative diorenzo yes
representative chase
representative muse yes representative
langley yes representative macbeth yes
representative page
representative simpson
yes
mr chairman yes you have it at 21 for in
the affirmative
zero in the negative
yeah you adopted the recommendation of
ought to pass on senate bill 399 by a
vote of
21 nothing
and do you want that on the consent
calendar
without objection right yes without
objection
okay that concludes what i'd like to
have everybody do is do their majority
and their minority reports and if they
could get them to me by by the end of
tomorrow end of business tomorrow that
would be really great um
i gave people a lot more time the last
time and i paid the price for that a
little bit so
um
i uh
i ended up chasing some people so
long in the short if um if you could do
that by
closing business tomorrow i'm not going
to make you do it today
we went through a lot of business in two
weeks and i really appreciate
everybody's cooperation in doing that
and
representative smith
um
mr chair it's my understanding
that
barring any surprises
this is the last
bill
to come before
judiciary
as a full committee and
the
the remaining issues are
fallen two groups one is assuming that
the house agrees to our
interim study
we would be forming into
study groups and
second if in fact um
there are any committee of conference uh
issues
but those would only affect some members
of the ba of this body so while we're
all here
i want to express
um
my
appreciation for the way in which
you
have conducted this committee um
without fear or favor
and respectful of everyone's
uh views and the views are disparate and
it was an honor to serve with you
and with other members of the committee
well there's a there's a lot of credit
to go around
first of all to everybody for their
service to the clerk you know
this is not an easy job that he does
the vice chair of course and
you don't realize it but he has to do
reports as a result of our meetings as
well and get them in as well and
and uh certainly uh the
the
ranking member on the other side
representative smith you've been
terrific to work with and absolutely
yeah and uh you were a great chairman
last session
you've been terrific to work with this
this time you
you know i i hear all the time in terms
of committees and committees that do
their jobs that
we seem to get along better than just
about anybody out there and and it's
just i think it's a credit to you but
it's a credit to all of you for being
cordial and
being respectful of each other and you
know it's just
just an honor to be here really it's
just a great committee
and i guess unless anybody else has
anything else we're
i guess research that the call of the
chair hopefully we don't need to come
back for another meeting like this
right